what we need out of all of this maybe
the Silver Lining out of this infighting
is not that the Democrats will will gain
strength they're clearly in the upper
hand right now but maybe maybe sanity
could be restored as enough of us just
keep seeing the insanity right you keep
showing us that Insanity it keeps
spreading the lies keep spreading all of
that stuff and maybe a couple people
will be like
you know I've had just about enough of
this
it does not have to be this way I'm
going to start voting for better people
I'm going to start voting for people who
say what they think and do what they say
and all of that I thought Ben Shapiro
said it quite well using only five words
in which week first party to sanity went
wouldn't that be something guys wouldn't
that be something if we could get on the
other side but we can't get on the other
side with the name calling and the lying
and all of this stuff uh Steve days over
at the blaze had a had a long tweet on
this and I think he explained it quite
well sort of what's happening right at
this very moment he said this Foster
clock is happening right now because the
Republican party is ensnared by a trap
of its own making most of the Republican
Party can no longer do out in the open
what it wants to which is betray the
base and pocket the money because of the
emergence of trump and his base
existentially disrupted their Paradigm
as well as expose the fecklessness of
the GOP to an unsustainable level Trump
and the movement surrounding him he
inspired should absolutely get credit
for that however Trump the disrupter
isn't much of an actual leader if you're
going to blow something up better have
something better ready to replace it
Trump didn't he really just expected to
make better deals with the same swamp
rats that were always thus there is no
counter Vision or new breed of leader to
rep to replace the surrender caucus with
because the only standard was will you
slurp Trump you have Trump loyalists
like Gates and Marjorie tailored green
on opposing sides with McCarthy
you got McCarthy as speaker at all
because he gladly slurped Trump for
power you have people with good voting
records like Gates aligned with total
rhinos like stephanic and mace when all
they have in common is Trump slurping
everything on the right is about one man
and one man only there is no vision
leadership and without a vision the
people perish which is why Democrats
have outperformed 30 special elections
this year by an average of 11 points
they have a vision albeit a demonic one
but a demonic Vision will defeat a cult
of personality every single time just
like it is defeating us as we speak
that's why Democrats are fine vacating
McCarthy 2 in order to expose these
fissures on the right all the more
divide and conquer is the oldest
strategy known to man that you're United
by a vision while we do Kool-Aid Acid
tests of loyalty not to a vision but to
a singular figure who isn't inclined to
return that loyalty all too often and
given his age won't be relevant all that
much longer anyway so what is the plan
what is the vision there isn't one and
there never was nothing has changed the
cake is still being baked the same it's
just the frosting is zanier than ever
despite all those zany hijinks we're
right back to where we started
Republicans focus on winning the next
election Democrats are out to win the
next Generation uh Steve days if I can
just give you a little golf clap right
there like that is it that absolutely is
it